European Union ministers will discuss
new rules aimed at better protecting
workers who are temporarily posted
abroad by their employers that talks in
Luxembourg on October 15 the EU is
striving to guarantee the rights and
working conditions off posted workers
throughout the Union it also aims to
halt social dumping where foreign
service providers undercut local
concerns with lower labor standards the
so-called posting of workers directive
is aimed at ensuring certain minimum
terms and conditions of employment on
things like working hours conditions pay
equal opportunity and annual leave but
it also obliges member states to grab
public access to information about
national employment conditions the
minister's aim to agree on a general
approach to strengthening those rules
the council will also exchange views on
youth unemployment with around one and
four people under 25 out of work on
average last year across the EU
according to the eurostat statistics
agency The ministers will take stock of
progress made with current initiatives
to find jobs for young Europeans in Lyon
with recommendations by EU leaders in
June the ministers who are responsible
for employment the protection of health
social and consumer interests gender
equality and equal opportunities will
also study this year's European semester
process the six-month monitoring and
support mechanism is aimed at helping
member states to better plan their
budgets and economic policies in
Luxembourg the council will look at the
employment and social aspects of the
mechanism to prepare for 2014